ja ich muss sehr falls ihr wissen wollte
warum schaut euch das letzte video auf
einem kanal an auf jeden fall wollte ich
euch heute herzlich willkommen heißen zu
diesem video wo wir mal etwas anderes
ausprobieren werden wir googeln sachen
und leute und wie ich darauf kam sturm
mir hat heute ein bild hochgeladen
werden eingegeben kelly missfiel ob man
kann einfach füße so richtig und deshalb
dachte ich mir
probiere ich das ganze auch mal aus und
geht einfach ein paar youtuber namen ein
und wir schauen was dabei rauskommt okay
probieren wir mal aus erst mal bei mir
selbst ich bin gespräch also ich hab
mich schon mal gegoogelt aber schon ewig
nicht mehr kran crafter vip shopping
okay also alles nicht so besonders
cooles bild übrigens da unten fünf mir
kran crafter alter okay ist ein
charakter ist eine freundin krankhafte
echten namen ändern games equipment
escape okay bei mir ist das relativ
unspektakulär weil ich behaupte einfach
mal dass mich so viele leute nicht
suchen bei google aber wir probieren
einfach mal ein paar andere lustige
namen aus wie wärs denn hiermit ab ob
wikipedia schuhe
apa/red ist schwul haben wir schon wenn
wir ab juli eingeben nach ist ein
probieren müssen wir weiter
okay das basler für das ok apparat ist
schule haben wir schon herausgefunden
immerhin stets bei google also wird das
alles stimmen und komische menschen
scheint es nur homo am ende wen können
wir uns noch mal anschauen schauen
einfach mal luca von crafter shop buch
dicky command okay ja gut das ist alles
relativ normal noch ist von craft ist
illuminati haben wir ganz oben
aha krefter ist thun heute auch iphone
ich glaube dass es bestimmt irgendwo
mission gucken wir uns mal haben wir
schon gedacht ja kann crafter ist zur
not auch iphone ja gut luca guten
appetit wünsche ich dir dabei ist tot
was ist das denn toten schuhe irgendwie
es immer schwul dabei probieren wir es
mal bei bei deene aus jener des ok ich
verstehe den er ist tot verliebt dumm
reich okay aber wir setzen mal einen fuß
auf unsere eigene szene raus und gucken
zum beispiel mal in die beauty szene
nehmen wir mal babys youtube palace bot
youtube testet ich alte ok alles
anscheinend ist der meistgesuchte
begriff baby beauty case mod ich weiß
nicht was man da google soll trotz fire
ist schwanger istanbul oder es dumm
ok ja die shops sind auf jeden fall
deutlich gefeuert worden kann man sagen
so natürlich klassiker wenn wir schon
bye bye baby gerade waren müssen wir
noch gucken was es sonst noch gibt da
gps geldgeil tod man jeder youtube wird
es wird immer irgendwie google ab
youtuber tod ist wir gucken jetzt mal
was man da so dasteht
bravo suchmaschinen-optimierung läuft
bei euch dass das kommt an
hater wünscht ihr den tod der babys tot
koma was sonst noch so vereins war es
vom geld kein wirklich nein da ist das
pesto zu fruchtig wirklich wie kraft
leute wahrscheinlich weil ich so viele
leute gefragt haben was das bedeutet
aber der hamburger wetter ja richtig
heiß ja falls ein paar von euch das
nicht mehr wissen was das war
da waren wir beim burger battle von
einer fast food kette und da hatte
justin fix wurf auch ein bürger
einreichen und er hat ja davor schon
immer mal ein bisschen gegen bari
geschossen auf diversen plattformen und
die hat dann spontan gesagt dass ihr das
pesto zu fruchtig ist auf dem burger von
justin und sehr gut was kann ein pesto
fruchtig sein
versteht ihr das ist nicht fruchtet
pesto okay wir können wir noch google ja
wir können mal ist tot natürlich der
klassiker depressiv spongebob wirklich
was für sachen gegoogelt werden max
fahne snapshot of ganz ganz viele suchen
anscheinend snapshot von mir können wir
die kommentar schreiben wollt ihr dass
ich mir ein snapshot count mache weil
vielleicht mache ich das wenn ich mein
abi habe müssen wir sehen auch schon
wieder sturm waffe ist auch illuminati
leute verstehe die welt nicht mehr ich
habe eine lustige idee gültig da wieder
was mir das okay probieren wir das ganze
noch mit einer weiteren person aus wien
könnten wir uns vor knüpfen wir mal luna
darko anadarko
und heute kommt ist luna dato und adi
zusammen ist luna darko und tadel
zusammen sind es relativ schwer deutsche
sätze zu bilden schreibt in die
kommentare leute das war jetzt relativ
kurz also ich hab gar nicht so viele
tolle sachen heraus gefunden
vielleicht hätte ich mir noch die
ergebnisse anschauen können aber
komme was bei com kraft des schulchors
matchpunkt de hämme super finde ich da
ist luca und wo mein gott da bin ich es
ist einfach unglaublich
markt.de okay das war richtig schlecht
ist